so the eyes are the first thing people  notice take us through some of the  things that we can do to reverse the  signs of aging around our eyes we  recommend RF micro-needling around the  eyes it's actually micro needling both  energy coming out of the needles and it  helps tighten the skin around the eyes  radiofrequency is a very popular  technology for skin tightening what does  that cost 2200 oh that's for celebrity  status so how do you get that celebrity  look without spending a fortune we  teamed up with dr. quan chi and roc  skincare for a more affordable option  ROC retinol correction eye cream it's  clinically proven to visibly reduce  wrinkles around the eyes by 50% what  else does it do it visibly reduces  puffiness and dark circles under the  eyes within four weeks okay I'm sold so  do I have to drive down to your office  to pick this up no you don't have to  even go to Walmart and get it for less  than $20  [Music]